[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour cédric cherche le bon coin ce matin
bref alors je crois que j'avais vendu
cette belle salle et non mais c'est jura
j'espère que tu vas te rattraper eh bien
je me rattraper ça apportera philippe
risoli paraît alors si vous êtes un
véritable émoi femmes
fais gaffe aux vans il n'y a pas de
compétences et par ap
c'est un véritable émoi femme mélissa si
si si si je me sens ce week-end il ya un
tweet sur un tweet peut être il ya pas
de prompteur peut-être pas tweet moi
c'est quoi un truisme que vous avez oui
voilà alicia keys paraît-il est
intéressé par vous ferai comme beaucoup
et c'est vrai que tout le monde vous
veut en tout cas c'est ce que vous dites
est en 2020 on parle quand dans le
sélecteur on parle plus de dents roanne
on parle de don juan ou n'a regardé
ma vérité personne n'est mon délire oui
ben ali chassé les rotors emma longoria
et margot roga quelque chose c'est elle
qui me choisiront une chanteuse mondiale
qui a tenté de pécho l'animal et le cerf
internationale qui morcellent dia son
agent pour que je vienne assister à son
concert qui me rencontrer ensuite dans
les loges année comme celle-là est fier
qu'une star internationale l'attendent
dans les loges
car elle a vu une formation et à la wii
si vous avez des wheat ailleurs swift
est donc évident au bélier ne se remet
pas de cette nouvelle regarder mais ce
n'est pas tout selon nous mêmes une
princesse qui vient de se marier est
folle de vous meghan markle elle me
kiffe elle aussi fera elle aussi donné
un melon comme ça à vous et vous êtes
sûr de votre coup puisque vous
connaissez quelqu'un qui connaît
quelqu'un qui te connais meghan markle
les séries en 2 coups de fil du jeu à
tous rihanna vient d'ordonner un
célibataire et vous vous savez
exactement pourquoi j'ai dit que j'étais
un petit peu intéressés de loin bien
entendu en amitié on rit à la caste yves
pas trois jours après c'est terminé et
donc moi je pensais que vous étiez la
seule personne au monde à croire que
rihanna avait cassé avec son prince
rien que pour vous mais non écoutez la
réaction de capuches chine c'est
magnifique
vous savez que rihanna avait cassé avec
son mec est pour ma personne
eh bien eh bien eh bien eh bien
elle est persuadée qu'elle a cassé pour
vous sacs et demi après toutes les
femmes qui veulent comme ça c'est pas de
conneries mais j'arrête alors alors si
vous êtes dans le top 3 des plus grands
animateurs télé lourdeur 6 il ya trois
personnes et matthieu delormeau vous et
vincent cerutti ah bah voila voila je
vois que tu avec du beau monde ça
comment j'ai calculé que chaque semaine
vous passiez plus de temps à cette place
vous passez plus de temps cette place a
animé des émissions que dans votre lit
et donc forcément vous êtes fatigués il
ya quelques jours vous avez voulu faire
une phrase pour conclure le sondage
en fait votre bouche et votre cerveau il
voulait plus vous suivre personne n'a
compris ce que vous avez dit pas s'il ya
une personne qui a compris en y
réfléchissant en fait c'est logique
regard des sétois jean mi c'est quoi
oui à 29 pour sow non non à 71% à ce
qu'il faut soutenir la keynote voyons
pas donc ils sont plus que non c'est un
peu comme ici il y en avait 2 pt non et
oui et des la plupart qui était donc
voilà donc voilà matthieu delormeau le
leader tnt as raison votre intervention
n'est pas très clair cyril et à la
manière vous allez voir dans capuche
chinkin des yeux on voit qu'elle festive
avoir compris votre fragments fait elle
a rien compris du tout évidemment benji
aussi qu'ils essayent d'apercevoir ses
collègues d'en face qui sont trop loin
pour ses yeux en espérant que quelqu'un
lui explique ce que vous avez voulu dire
franchement et valérie bénaïm la carole
rousseau du bled espiègle moqueuse et
surtout sadique
rires c'est adam déployés comme quand
elle a vu pour la première fois le zizi
de pathologies kelly vely vous allez
voir elle elle en train de bâiller la
bouche fermée elle cherche elle cherche
de l'aide matthieu delormeau qui peut
traduire n'importe quelle phrase
improbable puisqu'il a travaillé sur
nrj12 mathieu dont qui peut tout
expliquer en fait qu'une seule personne
qui n'est pas du tout perturbé par cette
intervention incompréhensible de serena
une personne pour qui a rien de choquant
dans cette phrase d'habitude c'est cette
personne qui la spécialité fera ce qu'on
comprend pas et cette personne c'est
bien sûr jean michel hubert arné pour
lui aucun problème
il a tout compris tout est normal ah
bien sûr vos jambes venturi bien sûr
tout était clair que c'était clair aller
aux dacquois doit alors dans les vieux
comics vrai qu'il y avait pierre palmade
michèle laroque
on embrasse mais si on a plus fort que
ça il ya isabelle et vous avance adore
c'est un duo est sans doute vdl se
rhabiller j'ai pas le temps sera bits
mais tu te parle
oui alors est donc entre les anecdotes
d'isabelle et les questions qu'elle pose
invitée elle vous régale chaque soir ça
se voit et alors on a réclamé c'est le
retour de votre série préférée france
prend 7 préféré s'appelle un gars une
grand mère
[Musique]
je suis fait engueuler par bassillac on
me laissait un message d' insulte parce
qu'il paraît que j'aime à le traverser
la route
oui mais je vous ferai écoutez pas vrai
mais ça c'est super alors ma question
moi est ce que vous arrivez à vous
projeter dans dix ans par exemple
au delà de 2 cette année et est ce que
vous arrivez à vous dire qu'elles sont
quels seront selon vous vos pires des
fois ce moment-là et vos pires qualité
et comment vous avez vous installé un
aller-retour à vous projeter dans dix
ans ils vont aussi oui isabelle non mais
c'est un pari entre copines de piquer
des trucs quand on est étudiant de
toujours en grève on avait le temps et
donc on avait petit à petit on apprenait
des choses de plus en plus de valeur et
un jour c'était un manteau et moi je me
suis dit je suis doué je prends le
manteau et toupie à la à l'entrée voilà
et donc comme à l'époque j'étais
sceptique savait rien pleurer et ben
et un pouce en fait on est blessé on
voulait le rendre sa vente bonne sens du
rythme et copines avec le jeune will et
moi aussi ma mère avait détruit pour
chercher son fils
[Musique]
mais vous le savez vous et vous me le
dit à chaque fois c'est pour ça qu'on
aime isabelle bien sûr alors une
dernière sur de mon chéri à une année
chose ok alors matthieu delormeau c'est
pas seulement un producteur à succès
comme hier soir sur ce but c'est aussi
un homme qui dégouline de bonté il
distribue les gentillesses à ses
camarades comme alexandre reynal à
distribuer les coups de matraque alors
matthieu delormeau ce qui le caractérise
c'est qu'ils commencent toutes ses
phrases par mois il est beau et surtout
il est méchant et que ses collègues
regarder la télé on n'hésite jamais à
dire du bien de qualité de vie et lui
propose même une promotion
professionnelle à vous et puis en même
temps à cette jeune fille qui est ici
qui est très joli mais il ya l'argent
bien sûr il ya est riche mais il
yal'image l'argent à la déjà ce qu'elle
donne pour l'argent alors je comprends
pas que l'énergie à midi
ce qui éveille matthieu delormeau c'est
qu'elle a le goût du respect des anciens
le respect incroyable avait dispersé qui
n'enregistre aucun numéro on est tous
par coeur mais ça m'avait impressionné
par hervé novelli 06 19 au 22
mais celui pour qui m'a tuer le plus de
gentils chose à dire c'est bien sûr à
celui qui l'a hébergé quand ils étaient
dans le besoin
benjamin castaldi oui mais moi j'ai
toujours trouvé que les animateurs qui
parce qu'ils sont connus font font de la
télé moi c'est génial ça me révolte
parce que c'est une famille de deux
comédiens excusez moi ils prennent le
boulot de vrais comédiens petit soient
comédiens ont fait râler mais fort
boyard le fait d'avoir parlé dans un
instant qui passe de la tête de très
méchant à la tête du sourire commerce
hervé harnois ça oui mais non ne savait
pas dire que le candidat ne sait pas
nager vous connaissez la merde mais
parfois il ya des spirales dans la mer
il se passe des choses et on court en
dentelles et dans l'essonne et le 10
puis commandes avaient combattu et ex
est derrière moi c'était d'excéder mais
surtout mathieu
il est méchant
cartonné
cartonné hier avec son dock sur meghan
markle et prince harry alors que vous
avez rendu à un horaire qui nous a
beaucoup aidés pour le calage des pubs
bas vous savez m'a beaucoup touché c'est
d'ailleurs matin est d'ailleurs que nous
direz-vous direct alors vous nous direz
dans un instant parce que il a une
déclaration d'amour envers celui-ci
alors c'est vrai ça j'ai ma petite parce
qu'on était chaque fois à 16 dollars du
fonds n'était pas du tout ce à quoi je
vous montrais aussi le malaise du jour
d'hier vous allez voir ça oui c'est une
candidate des chiffres 2 et des aides
qui chante du soprano allez pas vous pas
une bonne idée
merci et le blouson blanc très bon je
peux le garder ou pas non
[Applaudissements]